welcome back so we're talking about
neural networks which is a very powerful
expressive machine learning architecture
to learn arbitrary input/output
functions given that you have enough
training data so now I want to walk
through a little bit of the architecture
and kind of how you build neural
networks what they're made of things
like that so the basic building block of
a neural network is a neuron which is
this little functional unit kind of an
input/output node or neuron and to be
mathematically precise you have kind of
an input signal u that goes into this
node and it does some mathematical
operation on you to give you some output
Y and this could be something like just
multiplying it by a constant or adding a
constant or it can be more more
sophisticated so often people use
sigmoidal function z' these are called
activation functions where if u is small
the output is just 0 and if u as large
regardless of how large it is
the output might be 1 and then there's
some smooth activation function from 0
to 1 this is a sigmoid 'el or a
hyperbolic tangent activation function
very very common also neural inspired so
a lot of the neurons in your brain kind
of have these sigmoid activation
functions so this is really really
commonly used increasingly now people
use this kind of this rel u linear kind
of it's it's 0 up until a point and then
it grows linearly with you this is a
very useful useful building blocks that
people are using in modern machine
learning architecture and I could give a
whole lecture on all of these different
activation functions there's tons of
them some are better for something some
are better for others the rel U is very
common so is the sigmoid 'el so you take
that that neuron that unit and you start
to stack it either in series or in
parallel or both so I can put two
neurons next to each other and do a more
complicated function this function this
function followed by this function I can
have middle layers I can
for example do three different functions
from this output and then I can add all
of those up or multiply them or do some
other function downstream and so I can
build up this kind of complexity in
what's known as an artificial neural
network so here I built up this neural
network it's a network with nodes and
edges describing the topology of how
it's connected but it's artificial
so neural networks you know you have
neural networks in your head this is an
artificial one built up out of these
building blocks and the different nodes
can have different activation functions
you they can add up linear combinations
of their the previous layer and things
like that okay and then if you keep
stacking more and more and more of these
layers so each layer is doing some kind
of sequential processing if you start to
add a lot of these then you have what's
known as a deep neural network and this
is the basis of deep learning today okay
and so there are a ton of things you can
do with these neural network
architectures I'm just going to show you
a few here so this is this is kind of
the neural networks zoom my colleague
Nathan cuts made this image it was
inspired by the Asimov Institute's
neural network zoom this is in our
textbook data driven science and
engineering and this just gives you an
idea of some of the the massive variety
of neural network architectures that you
can design and so each color for the
different nodes means different types of
nodes different types of computations
that are happening there's also the
different topology of whether or not
information is getting compressed in a
bottleneck and expanded or in all of
these different architectures and this
is only a few of kind of the the
architectures out there in neural
network so really there there are tons
of different and every every year there
are dozens of new architectures being
proposed to solve different problems so
it really is a zoo there's a ton of a
ton of different things you can do and
we're increasingly learning through
trial and error and study and analysis
and lots of hard work by many
researchers which architectures are good
for which problems and so again this is
just just a few of them
so a couple of key ones I want to point
out convolutional neural networks CN NS
are really really important these are
used a lot in image recognition the
basic idea is if I have a big image this
array here I don't know if you can see
but there's a smiley face I took this
from Wikipedia what a con the new
convolutional neural network does is it
has these convolutional layers that
basically take a mask and slide it
across the image doing local
computations in local patches and so
what you might be able to do is pull out
edges or features and you would run that
through a convolutional layer and pull
out these these edges and then you might
run those through another convolution at
layer and another convolutional layer
and you stack these convolutional layers
and then you do some processing on them
and so convolutional neural network CN
NS are really important for image
recognition anything where there is a
translation invariant so you know if I
have a picture of a cat the cat could be
over here or it could be over here CN NS
can start to pull out kind of this
translational invariance that exists in
images recurrent neural networks are
really useful for audio and temporal
signal signals that vary in time like if
you look at the the acoustic signature
of speech in time and what these do I
didn't actually draw it but what you can
do is you can add these kind of feedback
loops so you can have the neurons
feeding back to themselves or I can have
different layers kind of feeding back
and so this allows you to have this kind
of temporal feedback where there's some
memory in the system it's not just a
feed-forward Network which is what I
showed you before where all the
information just flows from left to
right here you have this kind of
feedback network this recurrent neural
network that gives you this memory so LS
TMS long short term memory networks are
really useful for audio processing and
dynamical systems anything that varies
in time because they have these kind of
feedback signals which allow you to have
kind of memory so there's information
that it's just living here kind of
getting recirculated through this
network so that's pretty cool very very
interesting architecture another one
that I really liked a lot
and I use a lot is the auto-encoder so
here I'm showing you kind of what I
think of as a shallow linear
auto-encoder meaning that my nodes are
doing linear combinations just taking
linear combinations of the input layer
and what the auto encoder is trying to
do is take a high dimensional signal
compress it down to some latent space
this is Z variable that's all the
information I need to keep track of in a
way that that Z information can be
relisted back to the high dimensional
image so that X hat is approximately
equal to X okay so this is kind of a
compression decompression or an encoder
decoder architecture where you can take
big data high dimensional data and
figure out what is the kind of the late
in space what are the degrees of freedom
that matter and so researchers showed a
long time ago that you could reconstruct
the famous principal component analysis
which has been around for a hundred
years in this neural network
architecture this shallow linear auto
encoder network and since then
researchers have massively generalized
this too deep autoencoders where now the
the nodes can have nonlinear activation
functions and I can have many many many
many layers and get better compression
better kind of extraction of the
essential features of my high
dimensional data in this late in space
is Eve and that's one of the reasons I
like these models is because there's
some interpretability that you get when
you do this kind of information
bottleneck this compression down to this
latent space because there might be few
enough variables here that I can
actually analyze and try to understand
what these mean with respect to the data
so I think these are kind of just some
neat architectures you have
convolutional neural networks recurrent
neural networks you have these auto
encoder networks and there's many many
more kind of as much as you can imagine
you can build a network to do it and
maybe that's the last thing I want to
point out is that designing and
implementing these architectures is
becoming extremely simple because of the
explosion of open source software put
out by Google and Facebook and others so
you have Tenzer flow and pi torch and
caris which are these incredibly
powerful environments where you can
design
neural network architectures and then
train them with with training data to
build these very very powerful and
expressive models so it's a really neat
and also increasingly easy to design and
use okay thank you